Speaker 1: At this point, it should be abundantly
clear to anybody paying even the slightest bit
of attention to the US-Mexico border, that the
border is not open. The border is. It's just not
open. There's there's no nothing you can point
to. There's no statistic. There's no policy you
can point to to prove the case that the border
is open under Joe Biden. And so what did former
Republican governor of Alaska, former Republican
vice presidential candidate, former congressional
candidate, failed, by the way, Sarah Palin,
say, when she went on Newsmax. She said the
border is open. We're going to check this out.
This is another one of these examples of Sarah
Palin in her echoey room, visibly struggling to
use language to communicate anything of meaning.
In this particular case, speaking to
Newsmax is Eric BOLLING about the topic
of immigration. And this is an important
issue because the lies that the right is
telling about immigration are sticking with
some voters. Let's listen. Then we'll discuss.
Speaker 2: A country that puts the needs and
priorities of invaders over those who fought
for it. Well, that sounds to me like Joe Biden's
America. New York is booting homeless veterans,
removing them from New York hotels in order to
put illegal migrants into those hotels. And why?
Because these sanctuary cities can't handle what
they decided to take on. Let's bring in former
Alaska Governor Sarah Palin to weigh in.
Speaker 1: Governor, you an expert on
immigration. Let's bring in Sarah Palin.
Speaker 2: This pick, they asked for it. They
begged for it. We give it to them and they want
to push back now and they're going to move out.
Veterans who are having a tough time in favor
of illegal aliens coming in. Your thoughts?
Speaker 3: Right. I mean, the whole open borders
issue is bad enough. And the icing on the cake
now, though, is that our veterans,
again, are being kicked to the curb.
Speaker 1: Okay. We're going to go back to
it. Let's posit there the open border thing
is bad enough. Can anyone tell me in what way?
The border is open. And I really want to know.
I'm I looked and I said, okay, let's look at all
changes at the border from Trump to Biden. And I
can't find any way in which that border is open.
The Biden administration has repeatedly said the
border is closed, just like Trump did. They have
said people should not attempt to cross illegally,
just like Trump did. The administration sent
troops to the border, increased surveillance,
increased technology at the border, worked with
Mexico to deter migration to the United States.
And importantly, since Title 42 expired, the
number of people encountered trying to cross
has decreased. Despite the fear mongering by
Republicans, I was unable to find a single way
in which the border is open. It is true that
the Biden administration is respecting the
process when people come to the border and ask
for asylum. That is the law. That is the law and
it is not a change in policy. It's possible that
the Trump administration was ignoring the law,
but I can't find any way in which the border
is open. So if somebody knows, please tell
me. Let's continue here with Sarah Palin.
Speaker 3: Literally, as illegal aliens are
being given precedence over this. Now, there
are two issues. One is the veterans issue.
And it just makes me sick to my stomach. And
it makes me sick to know that our leaders in
government are not giving our vets their due.
We're we're not providing them the benefits,
the promises. And that affects every
aspect of most every veteran's life.
Speaker 1: This is particularly disgusting
because this is the same Sarah Palin who in 2008,
when she was running alongside the late
Senator John McCain, to be preserved,
for him to be president and for her to
be vice president of the United States,
she defended the Bush decision to go into
Iraq, which, of course, led to thousands
of American troop deaths and subsequently tens
of thousands, hundreds of thousands of injuries
and psychological trauma, which then these very
same Republicans were not interested in properly
funding the VA and benefits for veterans.
And now she has the audacity to say, oh,
Biden doesn't care about veterans. Oh, okay.
Speaker 3: But also, though, the open
borders, you know, in school and
civics in U.S. history, because we are
in skull, the definition of treason. And if it's
if this isn't treason, when you consider what our
leaders are doing in their aiding and abetting
illegal aliens and they're putting our safety,
the security of our nation, ultimately our
sovereignty at risk, we are being destroyed
by the left's open borders policies.
Speaker 1: All right. I think we've
probably had enough.
Find me some way in which the border is open and I
will report it tomorrow if anybody can let me know